all right um
well maybe uh the best way to start
would be since i'm sure many people
watching this won't know you are if not
most of them
um just kind of introduce yourself to
give everyone an idea of who you are and
what you do
so my name is jonathan pedro and i am
mostly an
artist i'm an icon carver which means
that i make images
based in the tradition of the church on
for churches for individuals
um following really kind of the canons
we would call it the
the standards of iconography and you
know
respecting the way that saints or that
christ or that stories have been
represented in the past
and trying to see in that a wisdom
that's been passed down and so
uh and so one of the things that i'm
doing as an icon carver
is i also study traditional symbolism
and try to see
you know try to understand it try to see
what it means for us today
and also try to apply it to the to the
world today so that
we can we can understand these stories
as being as giving us patterns which
explain reality and explain our
interactions with the world rather than
just these arbitrary
kind of strange fanciful stories that
are from the past
right and that's it's it's really kind
of great that with
uh you know looking at pre-modern
literature particularly but especially
things
you know involving saints and these
other kind of mythological characters
to kind of be able to approach it from
that kind of symbolic and artistic
standpoint so that it doesn't you know
just gloss over and say oh that's really
weird i understand what's going on
but actually try to work out you know
what's happening and like what's
you know because literally these stories
have meaning beyond
just uh you know you know people believe
you know really weird things
the most important thing to understand
is that there are innumerable ways of
this
of describing reality we somehow
still have this idea that a kind of
matter of fact
uh very let's say kind of forensic way
of describing reality let's say the way
that you would describe reality to a
police officer
officer if there is a crime we have this
idea that this is the standard of how to
describe reality
but that is absolutely not the case most
of the time you never you don't describe
reality as if you're describing a crime
to a police officer
we use all kinds of imagery all kinds of
shortcuts all kinds of compressions
in order to compress large amounts of
time into very short
short stories and so this is something
which the ancients understood very well
and so the idea that you would have
strange stories that somehow
sometimes have strange elements to them
um
we it's better not to understand them
just as literary tropes or literary
metaphors but rather
methods of compression and methods of
telling stories which encompass
things that are difficult to describe in
forensic terms and contain
more information it's like if i describe
a
let's say describe a boxing match and i
say that guy whooped this guy's ass
like that's way more descriptive than if
i spend an hour describing every
punch and at what centimeter from what
muscle and what damage it did to how
many blood vessels
like one of them is more forensic but
the other is more real
because it connects to all the emotional
all the meaning and all the
the deeper aspects of why you would
watch a boxing match in the first place
right yeah and you get that interesting
thing where i think often modern people
find things like saints lives
really hard to kind of process
especially and not popular at all like
usually it's like oh that's you know
these weird religious stories would ever
want to read those
it's like these were the super popular
literature of the day
in the middle ages and beyond and
there's and they straddle that line and
so far as you you'll have some which do
seem to kind of
they fit with our modern understanding
of that kind of historical
reports like there would be some that
have no particularly fantastic elements
in them and they're you
seem to be fairly sober and then you get
other ones where you know the saints
being swallowed by a dre
that's right and especially the earlier
it's like the further you go in the past
and also the more
the story tends to go down into the
popular sphere the more it will
have fantastical elements in it because
those fantastical elements actually
point to some deeper patterns in us
that that tend to manifest in in ways
that even though they look idiosyncratic
are actually
the best way to represent certain
realities
right i mean it's the the the story of
the hero and the dragon right is so
kind of universal or even just even
broader than that just the hero and the
monster or
you know whatever it happens to be is is
just in every
form of storytelling in some fashion so
it's not like it's yeah some kind of
arbitrary creation
yeah and even the fantastical virgins
that we have now like there's a reason
why things like lord of the rings or
harry potter
or fantastical novels are so popular not
just because they're flights of fancy
but because the the storytelling tropes
that they use
connect to some very very deep you know
uh patterns that we have inside us and
that kind of frame our reality right i
think one of the things that i think is
useful about looking at literature
like uh like st slice these you know
just kind of pre-modern ones
is that it it kind of removes hopefully
a little bit of that gap between oh yeah
there's these things we watch for
entertainment like lord of the rings and
harry potter that we like and they're
you know
we like fantasy right and then there's
real life and which is you know not
like that at all yeah which is boring
and not colorful at all it's just like
that's
that's such a such a modern
understanding like a pre-modern culture
just would not
understand what you're talking about if
you put it in those terms exactly
yeah and the story of saying margaret is
obviously a shining example
of a story that has some very wild
elements in it and
that it's it's important to kind of look
at to and to help us
understand you know what it says about
her and what it says about
why it was so popular like why people
cared about the story
right and i think one of the things that
is interesting
is to kind of understand how in in
pre-christian culture you had what you
might expect
as that kind of heroic stories that were
popular i mean obviously homer and
virgil
right you have the story of you know
gods and demigods and these you know
very
martial masculine heroes and then you
have this interesting flip that happens
with christian culture where it's not
that those things don't still exist and
they exist in christianized forms but
that you also have
explicitly kind of christian stories
which could not have existed before
that period of people who die incredibly
you know
shameful in the eyes of the world uh
right deaths of slaves that also
may very well have been slaves
themselves um and that but they're
raised up and this
has a kind of laudable or admirable uh
you know example of
right action so i know basically as a
hero and it's very much often framed in
terms of
overcoming uh right some kind of foe
even though that overcoming results and
usually be
killed um it's just it's such a it's
such an interesting kind of
reversal in a way it's kind it's
partially reversal but it's partially
participating in that same pattern of
overcoming
uh the foe it's just the method of the
overcoming has
shifted is different and so in the story
of saint margaret
there are a lot of things in her story
would really point to the things you're
talking about
within the story itself you know in the
the version at least that i read i don't
know if
this is in every version um say margaret
is actually
born of pagan parents who expose her
to die and so this was a practice which
was in rome
in greece you know in different pagan
cultures which is that
uh especially if a girl was born because
a girl
was seen as trouble then the girl would
be
left out to die like you know when the
father would see that it's a girl
and he would just leave her out to die
or if it was someone who was
slightly deformed or just in in a in a
wrong time or there was you know it just
wasn't the time for a child
then there was no moral they didn't see
a moral problem
in killing the child or exposing the
child for it to die
and so in the story what you have is
margaret is saved by a christian
person who raises her up in the faith to
become
you know a person who's very strong in
the christian faith
and is willing to stand up and to speak
out against the evils of the pagan world
so already interestingly enough you find
you find a
a contradiction in the simplistic way
people first of all view christianity
and the way that they view you know
ancient civilization
uh in general where one of the aspects
that christianity brought to the world
was
a value like a giving value to the
feminine
and giving value to the lower aspects of
reality the slaves the
you know it gave a way for people who
were marginalized in society
before to now to have a way to
to have a kind of power a kind of power
which is a spiritual power
um and so in her very story you actually
see what christianity did to the pagan
empire
which is to to take that which was
uh thrown out by the pagan empire take
also women who were
viewed as simply property in the pagan
empire
and bring it into christianity uh where
although people for some reason don't
can't see that this was what happened
that they they became fully human and
they were also
uh for example like uh you couldn't in
the pagan world you could marry a woman
by just taking her
whereas in the christian world uh
consent became
the rule for christianity is that a
woman had to give consent in order to be
married
um and so the story of saint margaret
has her being raised by christian and
being very beautiful
and very attractive and so she attracts
the
interest of a a kind of pagan king
or some kind of pagan authority and the
pagan authority
uh wants to have her and the deal is
he wants to have her and he wants her to
submit to his god
and uh and so those two things seem to
function together which is he wants her
to submit to his authority
and to the authority of his world uh the
authority which he represents which is
this ancient pagan
world so saint margaret refuses
and for that she is tortured she's
imprisoned
all these things happen to her um
and uh and so he's torturing her in
order to convince her to let go of her
pride
to give in to him to to finally you know
just
just give up this futile fight that
she's
that she's putting up and to marry him
um and so this is where the story gets
very particular because when
margaret is put in prison then she
encounters this
dragon and the dragon
comes to eat her
and so in the virgin that i read the
virgin uh that that uh that mar gave me
she doesn't get eaten by the dragon but
the more ancient version she does she
gets eaten by the dragon
and then in the dragon she pierces out
of the dragon
with a cross that she has with her and
so that kind of uses this cross
to kind of break out of the dragon and
to be freed from the dragon
um and this is kind of it's like it's
connected with her
fight to resist the temptation of giving
in to this guy right
giving in to this guy and giving in to
his god giving into his authority
structure
um and then ultimately then because she
after she she freeze frees herself from
the dragon then
the man comes back and then the torture
continues until she is finally
killed um and there's a strange element
too like
this is harder to understand like i
struggle to understand it there's a
the element of this this character this
christian soldier which works for the
king
yeah it's a very strange element it'd be
worth thinking about more because
there is a uh there is a christian who
works for the king
and uh he's the one who's actually told
to kill margaret
and and uh and at first he doesn't want
to do it and then she says
you should you have to do this this is
this is just how it's going to be
and so finally uh he kills her and then
he
sue kills himself he likes suicide
and their people die in uh in that
moment and so that's like a really
intense
intense uh i think i can kind of see
what it's trying to bring about in terms
of storytelling
uh maybe we can get into it after but
first we need to talk about the
the dragon that's the most that's the
most interesting thing
um and so the dragon in uh
usually the dragon is a manifestation of
chaos you would say
or a manifestation of these lower
aspects which kind of rise up
you know and uh and try to devour the
world and so
usually the way it's represented of
course saint george is the ultimate
version of this we're not just saying
george but also the image of saint
michael killing the dragon
or saint george killing the dragon is
usually the idea that through
through uh light through word through
meaning
then the dragon is pierced and is and is
fixed right
so imagine like a slithering chaos of of
things that you don't understand that
don't make sense it could be your
desires
it can be it could be a foreign a
foreign uh
army that's on the border that's going
to attack you there's all these
different versions of what that dragon
is
manifesting which is just this kind of
chaos which is
pressing in and is going to it's going
to going to devour you from underneath
you know imagine
you have all these bills that you
haven't paid or all these problems all
these things that
come up from below and then through a
through will through truth through light
all these things from above
then the demon the chaos is pressed back
down
and you know order is re-established and
so that's usually the way that it
manifests itself
but a kind of more interesting oh not
this story on saint margaret shows us
another aspect of the dragon
which is the dragon is really mostly the
notion of extremes you would say
of extreme something so here's the
opposite
it's like the dragon is something like
a tyrannical hierarchy like a corrupt
tyrannical hierarchy
and so instead of it coming from below
let's say it ends up actually devouring
her and it becoming like a prison
so you can imagine that for for for
someone who is a marginal person
who is on the edge or or doesn't have
power
then this this order becomes like a
prison that's what
and that's what she's in she's in a
prison she has this king who wants
her to give in to his authority to give
into his god right to give into
the thing which manages his world and
she refuses
so the dragon the prison this
call from the authority is all the same
image right
right the the dragon is just one version
of the prison in which he is
and the idea of course is that through
her
through her uh dedication to christ just
something higher
to something more true then she's freed
from that prison
uh she ends up being freed from the uh
from the prison and so that's exactly
what's going on so you can see it at all
these different levels and you can see
it as a personal level too
because for example the dragon of of uh
saint george is often represented to
people as
the passions right so this all these
desires that contradict each other that
rise up you know you can have all these
these contradictory desires in you that
are ripping you apart
that are devouring you imagine the drug
addict or a sex addict or anything that
that you could be
kind of addicted to um and uh
and so usually that's what it that
that's that's the thing that it
represents but here it's kind of like
the
the opposite of of those desires it's
more this
corrupt oppression that comes from above
that is holding her in and that is
imprisoning her
that she has to free herself from and so
it's it's fascinating to see how the
dragon
is almost used in an opposite way but
inside her it's also
the desire to give in like her own
personal desire to give in
to this man who is pressuring her and is
saying
you could just if you just gave in to my
authority to this
corrupt false authority then all your
problems would go away right and so
she has this temptation uh which is
different
because it's not like she's attracted to
him right it's not like like uh like a
like the image rather of a seductress
who would come towards someone and then
the you know the man has to resist his
temptation
her temptation is just the temptation to
give in
and to give in to the authority in order
to stop the suffering that she's going
through
so it's a different temptation but it's
a temptation nonetheless
right and there's this interesting
aspect too in that we have this victory
in so far as she overcomes the dragon
neither by bursting out of it with the
cross or
like in the uh 12th century middle
english prose version where she just
kind of makes a sign of the cross and he
disintegrates into dust
but she's still in the prison and she's
not i mean she only gets that when she's
led out to execution and dies
but that's that's the thing is that it
ultimately ends up being
a form of self-sacrifice which is
what uh saves her um and
of course in in the christian vision the
this
is also the idea in general the idea of
self-sacrifice ends up being the way you
solve a lot of the problems
right in the in the sense in this sense
as well
which is that the the the capacity to
accept
to suffer you know and so to not give in
to something you know which is false
and to not give in to something which
you know which is a lie you know and
this is this is something which you see
um happen in the image of gandhi or of
of different characters who uh or even
like
nelson mandela for example who accepted
to suffer
you know so to not give in to a corrupt
authority
and not you know mandela's maybe not the
best example
but but rather like the the the person
who just
who doesn't submit but then doesn't
necessarily fight back
but just becomes a an image of someone
who is strong and is holding in
holding on and doesn't want to submit
and then that has a transformational
aspect for them but then also for the
world as well ultimately
it's the whole image of peaceful protest
like that's what peaceful protest
believes is that
you you can transform reality through
not giving in
but not also rebelling at the same time
right and there's an interesting i think
idea of the kind of i don't know passive
hero if you want to put it that way if
like someone like say thomas more
which is narrative narratorized in a man
for all seasons by robert bolt it was
turned into a
movie in the 60s of this idea of all he
does in that story is keep silent
um and then they imprison them and they
kill him like that's the story and he's
held up
even you know even in kind of
contemporary secular
20th century uh west as this kind of
figure to
as a heroic figure even though he really
did the whole point is in fact that he
doesn't do anything
um in that he's just refusing to sign a
document and staying in prison
um but he's still there's a kind of
there's an activeness
to that facility though yeah and it's
also you could call it something like
the secret of inaction like the secret
of the
pillar right the secret of the axis of a
wheel the
and it's something about the cross which
is also showing this mystery of the
cross
which is this idea that at the center of
something
is the sacrifice like at the center of
things this is something that ancient
people understood
very much right it's something that
people understood that's why they
sacrificed animals that's why they
sacrifice people
because they understood that at the
center of a world is sacrifice
and this is something that for example
in a in just a basic way
it sounds all weird when you say it that
way but if i say something like
in order for your family to strive as a
parent
you understand that the that the core of
that is self-sacrifice
like if you sacrifice yourself for your
children
then you're then your family will will
thrive and you will thrive
right through that self-sacrifice but
rather if you don't if you
act in just based on your own will and
your own passions and your own desires
then then you won't be surprised that
after your
second divorce and your kids moving from
one house to the other that your kids
are going to start to not like you
and are going to are going to go in all
kinds of weird directions and
i mean it's like don't be surprised
because you didn't self-sacrifice
in order for your the cohesion of your
group or you're the people that are
with you to stay together right and
there seems to be kind of separation i
think it seems like in
pre-modern societies whether that's kind
of hunter gatherer societies or even
agricultural societies because those
kinds of cultures
the sacrifice is really present you know
you need to sacrifice in order to
you know work the land you know you need
to sacrifice obviously in terms of
hunting
to a degree and so there's there's a
kind of
experience where you're living it you're
kind of living that pattern of sacrifice
whereas if you're living in a modern
industrial society
where you can just kind of you know go
to the store and get your pre-made food
and kind of you know
you you become detached in this idea
that like something had to be sacrificed
at some point along the way in order for
that to actually function
yeah exactly but for us at least it's
easier to see it psychologically because
maybe that's the
that's the crux of our existence because
our our physical needs are so
uh you know you know are so taken care
of that it's easier to see
than the need for psychological for
self-sacrifice in uh
in a psychological manner or in a
personal manner um and understand that
you know that's the same for any
relationship like you can't if you go
into a relationship just trying to get
what you can get from it it's not gonna
be a fruitful relationship
you also there is a there is this kind
of mutual self-sacrifice which needs to
happen
for any relationship to be fruitful so i
think that that's what that's what
you're seeing in
in uh in the idea of the martyr is that
the martyr becomes
a mythical image of what christianity is
at a lower level and so it's sometimes
it's hard to understand why these people
would admire
these martyrs because you know like what
is going on like what is this
why is it so impressive to them it's
because
it's like an extreme version of
something which they experience
at a lower more common level
um and so that's why it was like their
shining examples were these people who
who were willing to suffer torture and
all these insane things
uh in order to stay true to something
higher were willing to sacrifice
themselves for a higher ideal
and they would experience it at a lower
level right it would be just like
okay so you know instead of when i get
my money instead of buying you know
uh some beer i'm gonna buy food for my
kids right
um and so it's like that's the that's
the level of still sacrifice that most
people
would have had to deal with right i
think this is a really important point
because i
i feel like already on the level of
dealing with murder stories right the
modern reader can really easily just
be like i'd never do like who would ever
do that like who would suffer these
horrible tortures just to not say
like these words like what why would you
even do that and if you go the next step
up
and and go to visualizing it and being
swallowed or almost swallowed by a
dragon
then it's just like well all connections
reality has been lost
it seems and it's like what is this i
can't interpret this at all
but when you put it in those terms you
realize like oh one yes like
maybe you're not martyring yourself i
mean martyr means witness right in that
case it's a kind of
you know in the christian context it's
witnessing for the faith
but there but it is even this kind of
pattern like you said of
of you know you you're with maybe like a
witness for your family or something
like that
um right and then you did the dragon in
this case as a kind of tyrannical
authority
but that dragons are usually symbolic of
you know
all manner of kind of you know like you
said chaos and passions and these kind
of lower things and when you put it in
those terms and the story like this
doesn't just become
detached from something that's you know
more historical seemingly but it's
actually it's doing the same thing it's
just yeah
like you mentioned doing it in terms
which we're not familiar with usually
yeah
well in terms of authority there are
some interesting examples
uh that that that can help you
to understand what this could mean like
i'll give you an example
i i forget the name of the saint
horribly
it's a russian saint uh in the orthodox
church where
this it was a an aristocrat who in her
city the
the priest was known to to have affairs
with women and
had prostitutes and whatever in his home
and she
and she knew about it right um and so
this yeah so you have a problem which is
you have this authority
which is corrupt and so on the one hand
it's like
you don't you don't want to rebel
against the authority to kind of
destabilize society but at
the other hand the recognition of this
corrupt authority and so you'd also
don't want to give in
to the corruption that this authority
represents so the story has her
going into the room with the priest and
the woman while they're actually doing
it
and and taking the woman out of the bed
throwing her out of the room
then turning to the priest getting down
on her ease and saying
father i need to confess my sins
and so there are other versions of that
like uh you know we talk about saint
francis of assisi there are images of
him doing similar things
where someone says what about this
priest who's living with a woman openly
and he says he goes down and he says i'm
not even worthy to kiss this man's feet
and so he's like shoveling ash he's
shoveling like
you know burning coals on this head
where all of a sudden it's like if he
doesn't change his ways
he's going to hate himself and burn
inside for the rest of his life you know
so
is these images of of how to deal with
corrupt authority that
can then show this how self-sacrifice
can actually transform reality
right it's interesting because in the
story she's actually she has less been
vective against all these guys she's
used you know
saying you know that you know you're all
gonna you know go to hell because like
yeah your gods are false and what
happened
but she at no point is trying to like i
don't know incite a rebellion
and we see that coming back to that
weird thing with the
her christian executioner at the end of
she says basically they do your duty and
kill me
and even he i mean there's again there's
a weird suicide at the end but the whole
point is that
it wouldn't have fit with the pattern of
the story for either her to lead a
rebellion certainly not but even for him
to have kind of yeah
and and i think that the reason if maybe
this is why i think that she was killed
by this christian soldier is because
the whole story is about not giving in
to the the corrupt authority and so
about a way to resist the corrupt
authority and so
obviously the the the the image of
the sword obviously has does have some
sexual connotation you can't avoid
those connotations when you read uh kind
of chivalrous
uh stories and this and the idea even
that there
there is this relationship and so in
being killed by the christian soldier
it's as if even in her death she never
gives in to the to the corrupt pagan
authority
even though she has to die it you know
the story leads to a point
where she actually never submits to this
this pagan authority
who's trying to dominate her uh in a in
a corrupt way
right i think that's probably why they
have the christian the christian
killing her right and her telling him to
do it so she accepts it it's not yeah
and she accepts that this is her fate
and this is how the story has to
has to go you know right well it's it's
interesting because
see so in a lot of ways she seems to be
a really good example of the feminine
hero
right the the way that that kind of
character approaches the battle with the
dragon in a way that someone like
saint george or you know in a more
secular context beowulf or what have you
is not going to do
um but at the same time there are these
kind of interesting markers
of uh of a still that's still active
sense like there's a part where she
takes
it's not so she's visited by multiple
demons the first one that looks like the
dragon then another one shows up and she
throws him to the ground
and puts her foot on his on his neck and
like dins in there
which is so that's you know kind of
violent and active but i
but i think even that is participating
ultimately it's still a kind of
symbolism of the feminine even though
it's a little bit more
no you're right and there is but it's
not just that there is a sense in which
sometimes these these stories when
it's like when when it's relating to the
also to the kind of foreign king
let's say there is there is a place for
a a interesting active element of the
feminine
you know which is like the idea of
rejecting
the foreign suitor or rejecting the the
foreign authority
so like that image of her pressing down
her neck
on the demon is in the bible there's a
version of that which is the story of
jail
uh and so jail is this prophetess and
this foreign king who's trying to invade
israel
comes to her comes to her tent and she
receives them in her tent
and then she acts like a kind of a
mother lover to him she
she gives him a blanket and she like
gives him milk to drink and so
she has him she puts her in this like
comfortable situation and when the king
is asleep
she nails his head down on the ground
with a spike
you've seen this story before yes that's
well i had actually forgotten about it
because i was thinking about uh judith
and the holy furnace
where it's kind of similar she seems
like she's gonna you know yeah and then
she cuts his head off i had forgotten
that it has this
almost the same pattern in that one too
with this but with the snakes to the
temple that's right yeah and so there is
something about the idea
of the rejecting the foreign suitor in
the sense of the the
the one that isn't your husband or that
isn't
isn't your authority or isn't your
husband or whatever
that all of a sudden there's this
activation that happens and it's like
you know anything goes and there's even
like a reversal where she's acting in a
like she's penetrating the the character
she's
penetrating the the foreign king uh in a
very violent and disturbing way but i
guess getting to come back what you say
before is like before you have the
societal shift in terms of
you know the the relationship between
masculine feminine being based in kind
of consent
of in a lot of pre-christian cultures
the woman had to fight off the suitor
right otherwise he's his wife so there's
that kind of like you said this
activation of
you know if if he comes to take you by
force you have to violently fight him
off that's kind of the way that you
express your you know your proper nature
i guess
yeah and it's possibly like one of the
reasons why they have it uh
because it would have probably it the
one of the reasons why it's the dragon
that she
that she ends up physically fighting off
is also
to to solve the problem of like you know
the problem of the the let's say the
christian martyr
facing his or her uh
you know persecutor how it isn't proper
for them to
turn around and and and be violent
towards the the persecutor so there's
all of that kind of going on in the
story
uh which definitely makes it a very
fascinating a very fascinating story
right well it's funny because like you
said yeah she can't she can fight
against the dragon she can fight against
the demons but she can't
physically fight against the actual
physical foes and yet
you know centuries later you have you
know probably the most famous
uh uh you know female saint for a lot of
people in the kind of the secular world
um joan of arc
hearing voices uh from various female
saints one of which is say margaret
but there you have a very different kind
of manifestation where you have i mean
she's dressing as a man she's
leading armies she's physically fighting
against the english yeah
but but then when it comes to her own
version of
her own uh martyrdom then she seems to
kind of
take a closer to you know kind of say
margaret role where she's not yeah
because
she she's doing it also the idea of
of joan of arc is that she's also doing
it
completely in submission to her king
like everything she's doing
is in order to save the king and this is
also
the the power of joan of arc is that she
saves the king despite how he
basically you know ends up uh
selling or selling her away to to the
english and and the reason one of the
reasons why she dies
in the hands of the english is because
the french king never bothered to
to lift a hand to save her and so
there's a tragedy in that
in that story um but definitely like
there's there is
there's like i said there's room for
these
feminine exceptions that you see in the
in the story it's like the
story of joan of arc is definitely one
of them uh where kind of she she joins
these extremes together in a way that
she's also a virgin it's important that
she's a virgin in the story it's like
she's this virgin warrior you know she's
almost
she's almost an amazon like in terms of
the symbolism like she really is
close to an amazon but it's like a holy
amazon something like that
right well it's interesting because
usually if you're looking at uh you know
things that are trying to find the kind
of pre-modern uh manifestation of the
the heroic feminine usually the amazons
is where you turn but if you read you
know if you look at
how they actually appear in the greek
sources they're really
something heroic about them they're
monsters they're monsters the amazons
are monsters yeah
that's right so you can see john of arc
as a saving of that monstrosity
like a feeling of the just like
christianity always
ends up including all the strange
elements of paganism back into itself
but
transforming it in a way uh that is that
makes it also different at the same time
right so what you can kind of conceive
of then if we're trying to think of okay
what is the feminine hero or what is the
kind of feminine manifestation of the
heroic
would it really kind of be something
that while it's participating in some of
the same patterns as the masculine
version
in so far as it it's some kind of
overcoming and it couldn't involve a
physical aspect
that there's still an interiority maybe
to it that's kind of
more emphasized i think it just i think
there are different versions of the
feminine hero
and i think that the virgin that we get
in saint margaret
is the let's say the people resisting a
corrupt authority
right and so that which and and so you
could see it in all kinds of guises
you know and the you know the woman
resisting a corrupt authority without
um without herself let's say betraying
herself or becoming the monster that
she's resisting you know
and so that's always the problem of
resisting authority and you see it in
any revolution which is
the revolutionary becomes the monster
they were trying to fight against
so how how does the christianity deal
with that problem and
stories like the story of saint margaret
help us to see a christian
answer to that problem and so that's one
version of the
of the female of the feminine hero the
other version of the feminine hero is of
course
the secret influence like the secret
influence is one of the most
powerful versions of the christian hero
of the the feminine hero in christianity
which is the one who moves things
outside of the story in a secret manner
and so if you look at how every single
nation converted to christianity
every early christian nation there's
always a woman
behind that conversion and you know
whether it's the
constantine's mother whether it's
vladimir kiev's mother
whether it's uh you know the the the
wife of different of the northern kings
in in western europe
it's there's always a woman who converts
first and then you don't hear about the
discussions you don't hear about them
but then her son her husband you know
augustine
uh the cappadocians in basel and saint
gregory it was their sister
and so it's just like it's a universal
christian story
of this this kind of secret hero
uh that that is actually turning the
world without
you know in a in a in a kind of silent
way by creating
i can always say it's like by creating a
space by opening up a space
for then then her male counterpart to
act in
something like that right it's
interesting because even in the germanic
tradition you have this sense
of often queens or princesses being con
they'd use the term peace weavers it is
that they weave peace
so because behind the scenes you know
whether it's through council through
marriages or what have you
that that they're actually bringing kind
of boring sides together but you
you don't they don't talk about it in a
kind of explicit way
yeah but it's also it's important
because it's an important aspect of
reality
and it's an aspect of reality which
because we are
so we have value the masculine so much
that we can't see it right we have
destroyed the private sphere we've made
everything public everything is
like this you know that there is we
we're reducing the
private to the the minimum and so that
was also
in tradition that was also the the space
of transformation
that happened in the in in a feminine
let's say in the feminine guys you could
say
you know that the type of transformation
that happens
the forming of the world that happens in
the womb with something which manifests
itself also at different
levels of reality this kind of secret
change that happens
um and so by overvaluing the masculine
now we think that that's the only thing
that matters
like we think that that's the only thing
that counts that in order for
for example a woman to have value then
she needs to act like a man she needs to
to to to to do all these masculine
things
and the other aspect this powerful
aspect of reality
is discounted as being stupid and and
irrelevant
and uh it's not it's super important
without it the world doesn't work
right yeah well that's and that's kind
of why i really
wanted to kind of look at say margaret
because i thought well you could look at
st
jennifer and that's also a really
interesting as we've already touched on
but it could be easy to just look at
examples of
the feminine hero that are very close to
the masculine
as opposed to looking at one that isn't
following that i mean it is a little bit
again we have the overcoming of the
monster but
uh but again like from if you're looking
at it from a
material historical point of view it's
like well she resisted the advances of
this guy and then was executed
yeah it's not it's not like you know
going out and leading an army and
overcoming the villain and you know it's
not like that at all
um and because i do think it does seem
that we don't
it seems like society doesn't consider
that heroic in the same way
um or like of the same value as the
masculine traits of going out in the
world and kind of doing something
actively
as opposed to kind of privately
resisting something um
and even to the point of of death in the
end
yeah because most of the time
in terms of dealing with corrupt
authority it's that's a problem most of
us will have way more than
conquering some other like something
it's like where all of us
in terms of in terms of the people we
have a feminine role
and you know compared to our authorities
compared to the police compared to
to uh you know to to the hierarchy that
that's above us
like most of the people you'll meet in
your life all have a kind of
relatively feminine role to play in the
social sphere so we need to understand
how transformation can happen in
different ways besides
conquest and all these kind of more uh
let's say the images of these more
masculine actions
so it's useful to understand this or
else or else you know
then we will just be bitter and we won't
be able to function in reality
right well is is interesting at this at
this time period you know kind of moving
from the
you know the eleven hundreds into the
twelve hundreds kind of the late middle
ages
of how there starts to be a little bit
of a reframing
about how these kinds of traditional
stories often originally oral stories
um are received in terms of their kind
of utility for the
you know whether that's the polis or the
other kind of the community at large
in so far as like there's a time when
these kinds of stories are massively
popular
in england uh and particularly say
margaret i mean
amongst the laity so clearly they
realize this has like
they're not just reading it for
entertainment although you know maybe
that's an aspect
but they clearly can feel like they can
get something out of it
but then as the uh more kind of
intellectual elite
type uh you know literate society starts
in feeling like these kinds of stories
don't actually reflect reality
um right because there's not dragons in
reality and they don't burst into you
know dust and you make this onto the
cross with them
they start taking them out uh to the
point where
in this this already in this 1100 story
is like well the demon looks
looks like a dragon but it's not really
a dragon and he doesn't swallow her
he just wants to swallow her and then
she makes the sound of the cross and it
goes away
and then eventually they just start
telling stop telling her story all
together um
and to the point where she's you know
kind of forgotten forgotten
yeah but i think that it's a this
move towards it's kind of like the
beginning of the pendulum swing you
could say of
modernity already in the 12th century
you see it starting
you know how this this kind of this kind
of move
from hyper rationalism to irrationality
that navy finds its highest its highest
easiest way
easiest version to see in something like
classicism and romanticism
you know in the in the modern age these
two these two extremes which start to
manifest themselves because
the problem is that this is why these
stories are so important because they
actually are a space of participation
in which the more irrational
fantastical elements of our psyche are
integrated
with the story in which you can
participate in right because saint
margaret was seen as a person that
existed
that you could look up to that you could
follow um whereas
now we have these weird extremes which
is like i said
the on the one hand the kind of critical
historical forensic
version of of factuality and then
harry potter and so then we have harry
potter and this and and we have these
two
things that completely have nothing in
relationship with each other
and the same person that loves harry
potter will make fun of a story like say
margaret
you know uh and so it's like in the
ancient world these there were spaces
in which these two extremes of of of
participation were joined together
in these more legendary stories you
could say
right i think it's a really important
point because even though you can read a
story like say margaret as literature
and you could read it like you would
read it you know
harry potter novel at least in theory um
there's a difference in terms of what it
was meant for and what it was
used for for the certainly for the whole
period of its popularity
throughout the middle ages is that
you're it's not
just a story that you read for
entertainment not only because you can
get something out of it of kind of
greater value than simply being
entertained but also like you said
this is considered to be a person who
lived and this is considered to be
yeah there's a reality to the story even
if we don't see it that way
that is participative that you're
actually you can enter kind of into her
story in
to a degree she would have had a feast
and people would have celebrated and
there would have been
church's name after her and city's name
after her and so it's like
there there would have been a way to
participate
in her story and to celebrate her story
that wasn't
like the kind of weird uh the weird
geeky cosplay stuff that you see like
that what that isn't something that is
kind of so weird and removed from
reality that it's it's just like it
it doesn't participate in life whereas
celebrating saint margaret and
and you know and celebrating her feast
and maybe having a procession or
whatever it is that
people would have done for her feast to
to celebrate her was something which was
integrated into their
into their let's say yearly yearly cycle
right there's there is a sense where a
story like this what it produces is
something like you know an icon that you
it might carve that's going to have a
different function
than a story of a dragon like you know
smog and bilbo or something from the
hobbit
right that might produce art uh but it's
not it's not the same
because it's connection to reality is at
a different level yeah like i did carve
an icon of say margaret
and uh and that icon it was for someone
whose daughter is named margaret
and uh and that is going you know and
it's going to go into a room and
she'll be told the story and uh you know
it's her patron saint maybe
you know that she'll she'll uh she'll
have a
special prayer to say margaret in you
know in her daily life
and so that's a participative thing and
so it becomes a model for her it becomes
a
you know like it's not like you said
it's not just something you buy
uh toys for and like that that that
is just this kind of fictional world
that you can't really live in
right and that's actually the idea of
naming i think it's kind of interesting
i would assume that
this story of st margaret is one of the
i think she's really probably the main
source of most you know people naming
their children margaret is probably
generally would be after her yeah
historically speaking
um and just how that's that is a
different process than the kind of thing
now where
it's becoming more popular to name
children after characters from
fictional things you know like oh i'm
gonna name my
trying to candle yeah the first time i
met an anakin i was like
dude what are you doing did you do it
did you watch the movies didn't you
exactly this doesn't end well
oh boy yeah but indeed there is
like this is some one of the points that
i've been making for a few years
is that there's a strange moment now
um in history where on the one hand
churches are trying to be as close to
entertainment as possible right and uh
have taken up the concert model
and using advertising tropes and you
know uh popular music and all that but
on this
in the same at the same time uh
entertainment is trying to be more
participative and so you have people who
like i said dress up as their characters
have cosplay events
there's something called the church of
harry i think it's called the
harry potter and the sacred text which
is like uh
an organization they meet every week and
they have liturgical readings of harry
potter books together
and they meditate on the meaning of
harry potter so it's like a harry potter
church
you know but you can't live in the world
of harry potter like you can pretend and
you can
you can have uh you can wear little hats
and you can you know but but in the end
it's it's
it's it's uh there's it's factitious and
it's schizophrenic
to try to live in a world like that
right well that's funny that you
mentioned that because one of the things
i think that is really hard to often get
across
especially if you're trying to kind of
introduce people the
concept of kind of literary study um is
try and make it clear that literature is
not the same thing as entertainment
there's crossover for sure it's not like
they're completely separate spheres
but the idea that we have there's a
reason why historically we have a
distinction between
literature as a kind of manifestation of
culture in a kind of higher sense
and entertainment it's just that that
thing that we go to kind of you know
have fun and yeah just forget about
steam off and to rest
it's like it's not necessarily a it's
not necessarily the idea of resting
which most entertainment seems to
to be part of yeah right yeah so
um i think that's i think that's
really really helpful to kind of put put
the story in
in all of these various contexts we've
kind of gone through a lot of a lot of
stuff
uh but i think i think all of it is you
know hopefully kind of illuminating of
of why why a story like this isn't just
you know a relic of kind of the past
that you can kind of you know
forget it's just silly or you know not
relevant or you know it doesn't have any
kind of you know we don't
tell stories like that today so how does
it how does it relate to
uh kind of you know the modern
conception of
heroism or happens to be but i think if
you take all of these things
into account then it really does
form a pattern throughout i mean it's
really explicit in the west i think in
the western literary canon
but even beyond that um this
this is kind of a structure of the story
you know how it lays itself out
and these symbols reappear and that if
we understand how these symbols work
then we can hopefully apply it to other
things that if you then go on and read
beowulf
only different kind of hero totally
different kind of story but the dragon
is going to be
somewhat similar in terms of what he
means yeah exactly it's going to be it's
going to be similar and it's also going
to be
something which can help you when you
meet your dragon
see the thing about the thing about the
dragon is that it's
it's if you give a specific thing like
if you give a specific thing which
appears to you as a manifest itself as a
dragon
it doesn't when you retell the story it
doesn't have the same power
right because it's not universal and so
a lot of times what happens in these
ancient stories is that
is that categories tend to con contract
right and so they contract
to a point where it they become
understandable for a very long time
and so if if you give something which is
too detailed
or too particular then it it has a
limited lifespan
right so but if you give something that
has
that is a contracted category then it
has a much longer lifespan because it
can it can kind of
cross through the the ages and so you
know there are certain images
like a dragon is of course the one of
the ultimate images
that is a contraction of all kinds of
categories of experience
into this very powerful image but you
can encounter a dragon it can happen to
you and then when you
tell the story you know you can give the
the details of it but
sometimes it's probably better to to use
a mythical image
because it's the one that reflects your
experience of it the most
right right it doesn't just kind of make
you wonder how many of the stories
that you know have maybe currency or
popularity now like how many of those
are going to last
if they're not participating in those
kinds of patterns as opposed to these
more ancient stories which last for
millennia yeah like for that's one of
the reasons why movies might not last
very long
because movies are so tight like they're
so the type of the movie is so
set like if if you have a story about
drug dealers and
all these different things and and you
know in a few hundred years from now
they those just might not be even
understandable to anybody no one would
even know what it is
that the movie is referring to whereas
the stories which
embody more universal patterns and are
using tropes which
can span through time then those will
just naturally survive
in the long run because because they're
not so idiosyncratic
right i guess that's kind of what the
the purpose of the canon used to be
insofar as like the texts which didn't
have that got weeded out over time
because they weren't copied down
and then the ones that were copied down
were the ones that lasted or the ones
that had some kind of
significance that transcended so like
homer is you know relevant
in all ages not just in ancient greece
whereas now we have this weird thing
because we preserve everything um and
you know and and also a lot of these
hierarchies are broken down so the idea
is like well you should teach something
as relevant in this political and this
is
you know it's going to speak to some
kind of current issue but like is that
going to
is that does that happen it's not going
to last forever because
one of the problems we're having now and
it's a it's a uni
it's a big problem everybody's seen it
it's the problem of the hierarchy of
information
is that we've created a world where
information is a near infinite
but attention is not infinite and so
there is a natural way in which the the
information will lay itself out in a
hierarchy to you
and that hierarchy will end up looking
in
look like a mythical structure you know
it it can be
especially now like with the social
networks and
google and search engines it can be
manipulated and it can be manipulated
politically which is
happening but nonetheless the problem of
a hierarchy of attention
is something that you can't avoid and
it'll make it that you know
the the the you know the third series of
some
random uh sitcom that no one ever cared
about
like the third season is just it's just
not going to be easily in your attention
span because it's so far
it's there's so much to attend to that
it's just gonna vanish even though
it might exist physically on some server
somewhere it's still not going to
it's still going to be on the on the
fringe of people's attention
right right exactly and i guess it's
kind of interesting that something like
this
you know like i say morgan has been in
the fringe probably
a lot of places for a long time now but
uh through you know
forums like this i guess i don't know
bring it back into people's attention
i guess well it's it's relevant it's
relevant today and also the reason why
it was
it was eliminated uh was maybe not the
right reason
and so i think that as i think that as
post-modernism has its way and kind of
modernistic thinking has its way it's
going to have a surprising effect
which is going to be restoring some of
these old stories that people
discounted as silly you know just just a
few decades ago
because a lot of the level of that story
is no different than the level of the
stories in the bible
it's like if you're bothered by the
story of saint margaret you know why
aren't you bothered by the story of
tobit and why aren't you bothered by
by you know the leviathan described in
job or the behemoth or all these
monsters and
the fact that god says in the first in
the first chapters of genesis that
he created sea monsters it's like you're
gonna have to deal with that stuff
you can't just you can't just toss it
off to the side it's coming back
yeah exactly but it's so much easier too
like when you know you
so you can look at the north stuff and
you see the the mid guard serpent
circling
the world and instead of that being like
oh that's just like a cool viking thing
he's like no that's like
it's in the bible too it's in that's
pretty universal my friend
it's pretty universal exactly it's all
over the place
we have our own we have our own serpent
encircling the world don't worry
it's out there somewhere it's great
all right well i think this was a really
good conversation i have to say um
well i hope it's useful and uh yeah and
to uh
and i hope it will also be useful to
your students